es un momento potencialmente histórico
en la lucha contra el vih los primeros
participantes de un ensayo de fase 1 han
recibido una vacuna experimental contra
el virus utilizando la misma tecnología
que ayudó a producir algunas de las
vacunas contra el coi 19 en un tiempo
récord el éxito de la primera campaña de
inmunización con aire de mensajero en el
mundo durante la pandemia despertó la
esperanza de revolucionar las futuras
vacunas lo que llevó a la organización
international aids vaccine a trabajar en
colaboración con modernas
estamos tremendamente entusiasmados para
avanzar en esta nueva dirección en el
diseño de vacunas contra el vih con la
plataforma de arn mensajero de moderna
la búsqueda de una vacuna contra el vih
ha sido larga y desafiante y contar con
nuevas herramientas en términos de
inmunógenos y plataformas podría ser la
clave para avanzar rápidamente hacia una
vacuna contra el vih eficaz y
urgentemente necesaria
cuando se contrae el vih ataca el
sistema inmunológico del organismo y
puede provocar el sida que en 2020 mató
a 680 mil personas sobre todo en áfrica
la vacuna experimental pretende
estimular la producción de un tipo de
anticuerpos que pueden luchar contra el
vih la tecnología de rn mensajero enseña
a las células conocidas como linfocitos
b que forman parte del sistema
inmunológico a producir anticuerpos
ampliamente neutralizantes del vih el
ensayo hará un seguimiento de 56 adultos
0 negativos para comprobar la seguridad
y la eficacia del tratamiento los
resultados de la fase 1 se esperan en